In the aftermath of the Battle of Winterfell,
beyond the thousands of men left dead and
injured, allegiances have shifted, alliances
have changed, and, of course, there's still
another war to fight.
Cersei is still waiting, and her army is ready
to attack Daenerys, Jon, and their allied
forces.
With just a handful of episodes remaining
in the final season, there's plenty left to
accomplish, between the quest for the throne
as well as another war, so here's everything
you need to know about "The Last of the Starks,"
the fourth episode of the last season of Game
of Thrones.
Funerals, celebrations, & proposals
As you might expect after the carnage of the
Battle of Winterfell, "The Last of the Starks"
opens with a slow and emotional funeral sequence.
Characters like Daenerys and Sansa are given
the chance to mourn loved ones, including
Jorah Mormont and Theon Greyjoy, who gave
their lives during the battle.
After a moving speech by Jon, the entire crew
retires to the great hall of Winterfell to
celebrate their victory, giving the characters
as well as the audience a brief respite from
the violence and sadness.
During the celebration, Daenerys takes a moment
to win some more brownie points with the Northerners
by naming Gendry, Robert Baratheon's illegitimate
son and sole remaining heir, as the Lord of
Storm's End.
Encouraged by his new title and still stuck
on his one night with Arya, Gendry rushes
off to propose to his lady love, only to be
gently yet firmly rebuffed.
Arya definitely isn't looking to get wifed
up any time soon, and being the lady of a
grand castle probably isn't quite as appealing
as stealing faces and killing enemies.
So unfortunately for Gendry, he'll probably
have to find a different lady to help run
his castle.
At this point, it's looking like Robert's
dream of joining the Baratheon and Stark houses
may not come true after all.
Brienne loves… and loses
Ever since she traveled with the Kingslayer
several seasons ago and saw his fall from
celebrated knight to one-handed enemy of Queen
Cersei, Brienne has clearly had feelings for
Jaime.
And it certainly seemed as if he returned
those feelings, from the time he saved her
from a bear pit to the moment he dubbed her
the first female Knight of the Seven Kingdoms.
After Tyrion shrewdly reveals that Brienne
is a virgin during a drinking game, the formidable
fighter is uncharacteristically embarrassed.
But once Jaime comes to comfort her, she gets
over that embarrassment pretty quickly.
Jaime, however, has to choose where his allegiances
lie.
Despite his seemingly close relationships
with both Tyrion and Brienne, he ends up heading
right back to Cersei.
As he leaves in the middle of the night, Brienne
rushes to bring him back to the Northern side,
but he insists he's really just as "hateful"
as his sister and leaves her heartbroken.
A Lannister always pays his debts, but which
scores will Jaime be hoping to settle when
he gets back to King's Landing?
News travels fast
The news that Jon Snow isn't Ned Stark's bastard
at all, but the legitimate son of Prince Rhaegar
Targaryen and Ned's sister Lyanna, has been
out in the open for viewers since season 7,
when Bran and Sam discovered the truth about
his secret royal lineage.
As the person with the strongest claim to
the Iron Throne, Jon has unwittingly made
himself an enemy of just about everyone on
the show, especially his new girlfriend Daenerys,
who is also his aunt, in case all of this
needed to get weirder and worse.
Even though Daenerys begs Jon not to tell
his sisters about his real parentage, Jon
can't help himself, swearing both Arya and
Sansa to secrecy as he spills the beans about
his royal blood.
Despite her vow, Sansa quickly tells her former
husband Tyrion about who Jon really is, and
naturally, he immediately tells the secret
Varys.
With information this important, it was always
impossible that characters wouldn't find out.
But this turn of events is bad news for both
Jon and Daenerys, who both stand to lose a
lot the minute the truth of his lineage truly
goes public.
Score two for the Lions
Despite the recent victory against the Army
of the Dead, Daenerys is more on edge than
ever, even during the post-battle celebration
at Winterfell, where she finds herself isolated
from the crowd and left to wander off alone,
seemingly angry at her failure to make friends
among the Northerners.
By the end of the episode, Daenerys has faced
two massive losses, both pushing her to her
absolute breaking point.
Not only does she lose ships and cavalry during
a surprise attack on her fleet courtesy of
Euron Greyjoy and Cersei Lannister's army,
she loses her Rhaegal, who becomes the first
of her dragons to be killed by humans with
the aid of massive ballistas known as scorpions.
In the aftermath, her best friend and confidante
Missandei ends up captured by the enemy, and
when Daenerys and her team offer Cersei her
life in exchange for her surrender, Cersei
has Missandei beheaded in front of them, another
cruel show of power from a monarch who knows
how to prove a brutal point.
After losing Jorah, Rhaegal, and Missandei
in quick succession, Daenerys might be on
the brink of succumbing to the madness that
runs in her family.
Even though Daenerys constantly says she wants
to avoid becoming her father, the "Mad King,"
these tragedies all point to her reaching
a breaking point before long, especially as
this war continues to push her to her limit.
Meanwhile, Cersei has long been one of the
most brutal characters on the show, and despite
Tyrion's pleas for humanity and peace, she's
not changing anytime soon.
For the moment, it appears that her ruthless
streak is still serving her well against her
more nobly intentioned enemies.
Will her commitment to cruelty be the difference
maker in the coming war against Daenerys?
Or will it be her undoing?
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Game of
Thrones are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.